Be An amazing movie about him.
Oh,
there will be.
Yeah.
And who,
who would play him?
Um,
good question.
Hopefully not a white man.
Christian Bale.
Uh,
let him get fat just like he did with Dick Cheney.
We played Dick.
If he could play Dick Cheney,
he can do Trump.
He could play Trump.
He was a great Cheney.
I thought I heard.
I haven't seen him with you yet.
I heard it was amazing.
You know the movie with like a lot of people,
the movie was good.
It was not,
you know,
it's,
I loved like the big short to me was amazing.
I don't think it was as good as that.
But Christian Pale is phenomenal.
He's a phenomenal act.
I mean to gain that much weight to become another person.
That's all thing with Jesse Small at.
It's like they're all,
all these actors are sociopaths.
They're all sociopaths.
Watches Good Morning America interview and try not to laugh.
Well now it's crazy what he said.
He's the gay Tupac.
Like you see that what he's saying?
He fought back and great.
Those guys like,
oh my gosh,
crisis PR firm is telling them to do that.
The Gay Tupac,
no one's telling them to do that.
This is all so this is Bridget Ferris.
Fetisi said it best.
She says she's hilarious.
She said,
this is what happens when you let actors write the script.
Well,
that's true.
See the plot twist coming a mile away.
I had the other night I was in la in an act was at the table and he was talking
and I'm like,
I don't know who this guy is,
but he's not even the person he is at this table.
Right,
right.
He's trying out a person right now.
Have you ever been in that situation?
I don't know who he is,
but he's not this guy.
He doesn't know who he is either.
He says,
no clue.
It's just good looking guy that vapid.
He's full of nothing.
He wants to get famous asap and they say things that other people are saying.
Here's one good to see you.
When they meet you,
they say,
good to see you because they might have met you and they don't want to forget
100% I,
I've said that before,
nice to me.
And they're like,
actually we met before.
I'm like,
fuck.
They'll ask in a very strange way,
they'll be like,
what's going on?
Like,
what's up?
What's going on?
Like you want it,
they want to think you want,
they want,
they want to be fed,
they want to be fed information.
It's like,
what's going on?
And I'm like,
wow,
you know,
a lot of projects he shit bro,
guest spotted flappers lot of things happening and uh,
because you're always trying to move.
That's the thing about La New York is just pound yourself into the ground until
you get funny.
That's kind of what the New York scene,
the New York scene is like two 57 shows a day.
Give up on your life.
Don't speak to your family,
they're losers are holding you back.
Go hard.
La is like,
make a friend,
have lunch,
see what happens.
I talked to some of the people out here and I'm like,
what's the plan?
I get nervous for them.
I'm like,
they're getting high.
It's mid day.
I'm like,
okay,
it's Wednesday too.
They're like,
we just had a meeting.
I'm like,
what you do?
They go,
we're talking about starting a podcast.
I'm like,
that's not a meeting.
You're just friends with someone else.
Yeah.
You're talking about stuff that's not a meeting,
but here's the thing.
It does work here and there are people that I know who've made the right friend
and then their life changes.
Yeah,
there's a little of that,
but those people are super transparent and if you don't have any talent that's
never going to tell,
never work,
and then everybody resents you.
There's a few of those people that really don't have any talent,
but they made the right friends and they cling on to folks and everybody gets
real uncomfortable in that.
Went off.